welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's secret invasion is
shaping up to be the most critical mcu
title coming up on disney plus with any
number of longtime characters in the mcu
secretly revealed as scroll
shapeshifters aka the punks who stole
this man's shoes in space he's not
shaving until he gets his shoes back and
now that more mcu titles are coming out
and trailers for future ones are coming
out quite a few new faces have struck me
as squirrel specious that i think we
need to take a look at along with some
interesting new tidbits we've heard
coming from the secret invasion
production go to omaze.com new rockstars
and enter for your chance to win a tesla
model x and support a great cause so
secret invasion on disney plus hopefully
coming by the end of this year is
confirmed to feature samuel l jackson's
nick fury ben mendelsohn as a peaceful
squirrel refugee talos from captain
marvel and kobe smalter says maria hill
more recently don cheadle was confirmed
to return as war machine brody and
martin freeman as cia agent everett ross
and also joining this overall all-star
cast is kingsley benadir playing the
lead villain oscar winner olivia coleman
mother of dragons herself amelia clark
kylian scott christopher mcdonald and
carmine jogo now it's been highly
speculated though unconfirmed officially
that amelia clarke is playing skrull
queen varanki the major antagonist of
the secret invasion comics and set
imagery revealed a newspaper that
mentions a u.s president ritzen
apparently played by dermot mulroney
giving us the mcu's new american
president that's exciting also in that
newspaper christopher mcdonald looks
like he's playing a tv news personality
maybe someone like piers morgan or
dailybugle.net host j jonah jameson in
this kind of story you just need some
pundits screaming over the airwaves now
secret invasion in the comics came about
after the civil war event when earth was
less stable with the planet superheroes
divided so varenke led an infiltration
of human society on every level
including the avengers actually begins
when elektra is revealed to have been a
squirrel named pagon and during that
scroll's autopsy hank pym reveals
himself to be a scroll and attacks reed
richards and a ton of other characters
reveal themselves like edwin jarvis
squirrel dum-dum duke scroll eventually
everyone including real-life political
figures like barack obama and john
mccain stephen colbert all impersonated
by scrolls the whole appeal of the
storyline was the question who do you
trust now the marvel cinematic universe
has of course changed the way we look at
the squirrels like in captain marvel the
squirrel group led by taylors were
allies to humanity it was the cree for
the bad guys the squirrels continued to
work as partners with nick fury and
maria hill through spider-man far from
home and then in juanavision's first
post-credits scene however the squirrels
in the mcu are a scattered group of
nomads with a variety of agendas like
taylor's group were allies to nick fury
but there could be other groups of
squirrels with more hostile invasive
ambitions and that could be the group
led by emilia clarke as varanki and
kingsley benadir's girl villain
character really i just think it's a
more interesting story direction if it's
not all humans versus all scrolls it's
really heroes and villains on both sides
among both races so that brings us back
to the question who in the mcu that we
already know have actually been
squirrels in disguise the whole time
like we know nick fury and maria hill
have at some points in their lives had
skrull imposters talos and sorin filling
in for them now we didn't see where the
real maria hill was after she morphed
back into soren in the far from home
post credit scene so it is possible that
soren could have been posting his maria
hill for the entire time that we've
known maria hill we also know of course
that government agent who recruited
monica rambo at the end of juan division
she was also a scroll now when we look
at everyone else in the mcu let's lay
out five parameters one they must be
alive because when squirrels die they
revert to their scroll forms so anytime
we saw a character die and that didn't
happen it means they weren't a squirrel
though we should also note bleeding or
major bodily wounds would look normal
because in captain marvel we learned
that squirrels can mimic the tissue of
their host down to the molecular level
we talking cheek swab or urine sample no
the dna would match second parameter
it's more likely they're pretending to
be human and that they're on earth just
because it's less interesting to see an
extraterrestrial character revealed to
be a different extraterrestrial like
groot is already interesting gamora is
already green third parameter it's more
likely that the suspect be not super
powered already because skrulls can only
mimic superpowers if they are what's
called super scrolls and while that
concept could get introduced in the
series i think they're gonna wait to
reveal that later on after that initial
wave of scroll reveals just to avoid the
complication and let those first reveal
stand on their own dramatic weight and
then later on heighten it from there
with the whole idea of super scrolls
fourth parameter to have the biggest
narrative impact we're looking at
characters who've been around for a long
time who we already trust and characters
for whom being revealed as this girl
would not ruin other future story plans
for the character in other words we want
the fact that they are skrull to be the
most interesting thing about them and
fifth parameter to best embody the
overall paranoia theme of the series
we're looking for characters in
authority positions or otherwise
adjacent to power or influence so that
when they're revealed as a scroll it
kind of freaks us out so all this is a
way of saying the big time a-listers
like peter parker wanda maximoff steven
strange thor bruce banner captain marvel
shang chi marvel definitely has bigger
plans for all these characters than for
them to be revealed as scroll imposters
their entire lives those characters can
certainly be mimicked as scrolls at some
point in the future but to say that
bruce banner was also a scroll for his
entire life
it just kind of sucks thanks to omaze
for sponsoring this video omaze is a
fundraising platform that gives you a
chance to win once-in-a-lifetime
experiences and awesome prizes while
raising money for non-profit
organizations you can enter for a chance
to win a brand new tesla model x plaid
this bad boy is all-electric has over a
thousand horsepower and has a 313-mile
range on one charge the stylish suv has
a six-month wait to get one from a
dealership but you can enter for a
chance to win one on omaze you'll be
helping support two different charities
give power is a charity on a mission to
help the 2.2 billion people around the
world who don't have access to safely
managed drinking water and then 501c3 is
a new type of non-profit for a younger
generation focused on energy food water
and shelter other campaigns on omaze let
you enter for a chance to win a lake
house or a tricked out bmw and support
causes like after school all-stars and
the charles their own africa outreach
project so for your chance to win a
tesla model x plaid and support two
great causes go to omaze.com new
rockstars so one suspect has been james
rhodes our man roadie war machine he is
confirmed to be in this series but i
just don't know he's gonna star in his
own armor wars series i don't think we
need that series to be a scroll show too
and in civil war the guy was seriously
incapacitated
i just don't know if a skrull could have
kept up that guy's the whole time
everett ross though is a likelier scroll
suspect because he's somewhat lower
profile a government employee appeared
in the background of a couple marvel
titles the only issue is he was also
incapacitated during black panther so
marvel would just have to establish some
new rules that skrulls can stay
shape-shifted while passed out or
sleeping and if they do that keep an eye
on our man happy hogan who has often
been sleeping and was also hospitalized
in iron man 3 but he is a major mcu star
that i think would turn a lot of heads
but in a way that i think fans would
really love i don't think it ruins happy
hogan at all if he is revealed to be a
scroll and it does fill that role that
edwin jarvis did in the comics i think
it'd be hilarious to see jon favreau
have to put on that squirrel makeup now
many over the past year have speculated
sharon carter given her shady moves in
the falcon the winter soldier but i
think revealing her as the power broker
was the one big twist for that character
and i don't know why she would use that
black widow face cloaking tech in the
final episode if she could just
shape-shift into anyone now from
spider-man no way home dodc agent cleary
emerged as a suspect for this line and
nick fury has been off planet for the
last year
what yes for him to know of nick fury's
whereabouts in space suggested the guy
must at least be subscribed to the
scroll lister and then from eternals
there was karoon who seemed to admire
non-humanoid forms it's a beautiful
creature the guy was not too shaken to
hang out with beans from outer space and
also didn't seem too broken up when
earth was going to be destroyed almost
as if he knew a way to get off world
there was val from the falcon the winter
soldier and black widow definitely
remains a possibility especially since
her character had links with the skrulls
in the secret invasion prelude comics
with nick fury it just seems like the
big reveals for her are gonna be in
association with the dark avengers or
something armor wars not ruling her out
as a squirrel i just think there are
other interesting places for the
character to go that have nothing to do
with being a scroll i definitely think
characters in kamala khan's orbit are
gonna be revealed as scrolls like her
crush cameron or her mentor najma as a
way to bring kamala into the marvels i'd
be very surprised if no scrolls show up
in miss marvel now samuel l jackson said
he filmed secret invasion at the same
time he shot two other mcu films the
marvels and ant-man and the wasp
quantomania to me that suggests that one
or more characters in scott lang's orbit
could be scrolls i've always loved the
idea of hank pym being revealed as a
scroll just as he was in that first wave
in the comics and would explain his
brilliant technological wizardry and
then luis being revealed as a scroll
seems like a fun twist that doesn't
contradict his character and give him
even more fun stories to tell could also
be a fun reveal for every time he was
doing the voices of the other characters
in his story reflected how in his past
he has himself embodied those people in
physical forms too so really i think
it's secret invasion we're going to see
a first wave of squirrel reveals with a
handful of supporting characters those
government agents that we mentioned
maybe president ritzen just to scare us
enough into thinking anyone could be a
scroll and really kick off that who do
you trust guessing game and then after
that build up to someone in the central
avengers core someone like hank pym or
happy hogan but i want to hear from you
who do you think is this girl comment
down below go to omaze.com new rockstars
and enter for your chance to win a tesla
model x and support a great cause and
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eaboss following your rockstars
subscribe to rockstar for more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you